中大版周报
公开版273集
台股非常非常的戏剧性
当然也许韩古更夸张了
我们一度呢
四万点大关
微微的失守
但是我们又迎来了一个
史上最大涨点
竟然涨到三千两百点
所以整个收盘又收回了
四万点大关
但是我们又迎来了一个
史上最大涨点竟然涨到三千两百点
所以整个收盘又收回了43,000点
真的是很夸张的
但是一来一回中
有的人可能很淡定
有的人觉得自己的持股已经受伤了
其实这礼拜的大盘的大幅的波动
刚好给我们投资朋友一个很好的教材
很好的教材案例
因为如果你是做长期操作的
或者是现股操作的
坦白讲这个礼拜只有心理的一点压力
但是还不至于说
有逼着你一定要卖股票的压力
可是有的股票跌很惨
因为你只要卖好公司的股票
他早晚都会回来
我觉得这礼拜相对的一些
之前用融资买的
或者是把你的杠杆开到的
你就有压力
为什么
你的时间容不虚你
而且大盘杀盘的空间
也容不虚你
有这样的情况
所以你会发现
在这波当中
上半周跟下半周
如果是用限股操作
你到最后会发现
根本没发生过什么事
在这个礼拜当中
我们可以发现
大盘的下降趋势线
四万五千点附近
我们上礼拜已经提醒大家
反弹上去四万五千点附近
一定要先做一个
把持股比重降低
我很少把持股比重往下修正
我们上次提到过
四万五附近
你就把你的比重
降低到五成左右
最主要我认为是
大盘应该会有机会
再拉回来测一次
甚至会有机会去破底的部分
那我们也可以发现到
上个礼拜呢
投信上半周难得出现
这一波的头一次卖操
不枉费我在投信头部
那个面待那么久
因为我们某种程度
我们大概有个那种敏感度
就是这个大盘这一波
应该会有一些压力
所以会先卖
但你会发现下半周
投信又再买回来
所以他也先
跟我们做法有没有很相似
先高出再低接回来
那这次的融资出现大减
首度回测到半年线
见到跌升反弹
那坦白讲这一波的跌升反弹
我这波我今年以来都没有买到
都没有用那个指数型的正额的
这次呢在4万点以下
我今年以来头一次用到两倍的ETF
可是这样也算可以杠杆呢
因为4万点以来
因为我知道那个位置是超跌
我待会儿再跟各位讲
为什么我今年都不用两倍的EQF
难得会在这个位置来用
好
那我们来看一下长线的支撑
外资的卖超加大
之前卖超加大
虽然礼拜五有买超
不过整体看起来是卖超
而且它这波拉回的时候
空单没有明显下降
礼拜五虽然降个1000多口
其实相对它先前这个8万多口来讲
坦白讲算是
这个算是有点破无奈
小补回来
投信的买超的部分变小
当然是因为之前
这个部分在45,000的时候变小但它拉回来的时候就变比较大我个人认为说这个指数曾经拉回到超级的稳健区所以这个部分欠钱投资人就可以做一个买进
投信近期的布局成本大概有算算还是在4万4左右
所以投信为什么在低档愿意买
是因为如果在低档买的话
他可以把那个成本稍微再做下降
同时我们上次有提到过
周大涨2000点获利的部分
已经从周大跌
先做大跌再获利
坦白讲你有发现
这个礼拜你能够赚到钱
是不是因为先大跌一段
你才能够赚到后面的三千多点
所以还是老外居
先阶段的模式会有这种调整
那我个人认为说先大跌后的反弹
日后如果回到4万5附近
大概就还是维持到持股50%左右
因为毕竟这个大盘在4万5以上的压力
还是蛮重的
我们之前等待已久的长下引线
我之前一直试图要画一个长下引线
我那时候不确定
但这次的39384终于出现了
换句话说39384可能会把我们原先26395跟31705
这条的上升趋势线做一个调整
上周低档分批布局的虽然有短暂套
但是后来跌生反弹你会发现
后来都陆续进入到一个获利的部分
我们可以发现为什么在这波当中
我会在礼拜三礼拜四的时候
破4万点敢买
是因为各位发现
原本呢
股票的股价是狗
然后这条黄色线是主人
难得狗跟主人很接近
如果你长期看我的影片应该很清楚
我一直强调过
台湾最合理的价值的位置区
就是40,500以下
都算是超合理
因为那天连的涨幅
变成38%左右
但是台湾今年企业获利有四成以上
换句话说股票的涨幅比获利的增幅来得小
就表示这么大超跌的
所以我难得有超跌我当然要买
所以如果按照我们上礼拜有
在我们的公开版隐藏版我们的订阅户
我有给大家一个我所设的一个所谓的
分批买进的这个部位
如果按照我的部位操作的话
现在应该都是赚钱
因为毕竟我们之前在48000、46000出
然后陆续到45000后面有再出
那后来到43000、42000有再陆续买进
持股部位依照我当时的建议是到8成到9成
所以建议如果反弹到43500以上的话
可以再陆续就把它尖码
8到9成陆续把它降到5到6成
其实两三成的持股部位也算是不如小补
7月份大盘是下跌将近6.51%
坦白讲面对即将未来的8月份
我个人认为说至少你可以舒缓一口气
那我不会因为说因为7月31号最后一天大涨
而改变我原先的大盘的看法
第三季呢
7月份是历年来第三季上涨几率最高
上涨几率最高就这样子
怎么这样子
我们看过去这10年当中
7月上涨几率是80%左右
8月是70%
9月只有30%
换句话说你可以想而知
未来的8月跟9月
依然还是处于盘整格局比较高
7月份的跌幅6.51%如果从我们过去的10年当中你可以发现8月的涨幅不容易去超越举个例子2024年的7月跌3.62%
然后2021年跌2.86%
但是你要发现8月份的跌升反弹的涨幅
都没办法把7月份的跌幅吃下
换句话说
下次的8月份如果接近到整个6月底的收盘指数
也就大概落在4万6左右
你就知道更要注意压力
因为它不容易去把它的
这个所谓的跌幅去克服
所幸的是过去来看
7月份跟8月份没有连跌
那7月份跟8月份没有连跌
那表示7月31号的这个收盘指数
相对来讲
未来如果地比较多的时候
你就要勇敢买进
但如果这个比7月底的收盘指数高很多
你就要稍微要解码
我这样讲的应该很清楚
那8月初呢
我们就续等谍升反弹
曾经我在电视板讲的
这一波呢
将近有这个2.4兆的金额部分
都在这个41500点以下买进
所以呢
会有出现这样的一个情况
坦白讲呢
这个月的7月份的走势
告诉投资朋友一个情况就是
台股从2024年以来
图上可以发现到
你可以发现一个情况就是
台股除了美股关税
和这个特别事件以外
因为那个是临时性的
大概没办法预期的
否则你会发现
多头顶多只有拉回一个月
那这波呢
大盘最近上涨起来
你有发现
就是之前的三月份
还有这次的七月份拉回
换句话说
整个多头的格局架构没有改变
而且重要的是
月的收黑K的线
到现在目前还没有出现
把前两个月的红K线吞噬
也就是说7月份可以把6月份
涨的部分可以吃掉
但是可能很难把5月份的点数吃下
5月份的红K线低点是39,228点
换句话说要来到这个位置
真的是有点难的部分
这波的大盘拉回0.5倍
0.5倍的位置大概如果在41910
曾经失守
那我们之前曾经在那个位置建议要买
那当然失守
但是最后面
你带我430000
还是赚钱
那最大的关卡就是
如果拉回0.618的话
就是39961
大概是首4万点关卡
也差不多跟这波的位置点非常坚级
所以
某种程度你还是要去算一下
整个市场上的走势部分
这张是我之前在6月21号
第261的公开版
坦白讲
我讲行情部分
都有我的前后的脉络
我们可以发现
之前在48,218.5上次提到过
我泼你冷水
很多投资朋友真的有接受泼冷水
所以愿意卖在46,500-48,000这附近
后来台积电我有提醒你
台积电的1.1
到上礼拜的时候提醒45,000附近
一定要降低持股比重
这波我们从50%的持股比重一路加码
就是我图上所画的红色区块
我们在隐藏版当中
我們的客戶應該都有按照
如果按照我的模式的話
都應該是可以買到相對合理的位置
因為禮拜五的收盤位置是比我們在紅色框框這塊位置買的來的低那這块位置是什么叫做稳健区那你发现这波的最低是39380我的超级稳健是39500点到36000
换句话说
难得可以来到超级稳健区
这是难得可见的
我当然要用两倍一提补来做
至少正二是市值型的杠杆
对不对
只要市值不消失就不要太担心
所以我还蛮开心
这样十几%还不错
那坦白讲这一波
之前真的也不会建议再杀梯
未来我也认为不会容易再杀梯
各位如果还记得
之前有个劳动基金
550亿的银弹
他之前提到过
最快会在7月的中下旬会上唐
所以我个人认为预估
在这个7月底的下旬这边
相关的劳动基金应该有进来去买
因为你会发现
最近涨的是不是都是大群群之股
所以你不用去等待国安基金
国安基金这时候是不会进场的
如果你注意看国安基金进场的条件
现在都不符合
一点都不符合
国安基金要等到什么时候
可能要什么
打折再打折
它才会再进来
现在这个还不到
还不到这种情况
如果大盘像国具那种
像国具那样子
那国安基金就会进来
这个不会
我跟你讲
百分百基本上不会进来的
所以我想最近
你还是要偏向一些大型肌肉股
跟高股息值利率的个股
因为这波会进来
有将来550亿的部分
大概就应该就是
这些劳动基金
就会进来的部分
那我们上次提到过
九大头股看台股
今年的低点是4万点
那你想九大头股都看4万点
我们算了模式都一模一样的
所以呢
我为什么说两杯贴股
我难得会进去买
而且稍微买的比较多一点
难得是因为4万点
九大头顾都这么看
大家也要相信
大家的看法都是一样
所以我们可以发现到
这个4万点来到
我个人不容易再杀地下去
那未来来讲的话
如果有再回来
你再布局
但是你也想
会有机会来到4万点吗
不会了
因为融资亦洗那么多了
那整个来看的话
第三季我之前在6月11号
第261集有提到过了
第三季最大跌幅是9.45%
如果按照那算的话
就是到9月底的时候
应该在41765
换句话说在41765以下
就叫做超跌
而且是什么
可遇不可求
换句话说
你就错过这一次的机会
那我个人觉得
如果有相关的一个内容部分
获得一些大盘走势
我待会在隐藏版来做说明
因为时间有限
这段时间虽然感觉上股市的震荡很大
但因为中小型股这一波
是比较带头杀的
以大盘来说
大概修正幅度就是20%的附近
在这个附近国安基金可能是不会动用
可是政府其实有对我们做了很多的信心喊话
也拉金融
也有拉所谓的台积电等等的
那钟大胆觉得7月的金涛鲍浪过了之后
8月会比较平顺一些些
这个是一个好的讯息
但是细节的操作
我们会放在VIP隐藏版里面
同样的如果觉得钟大胆这一波的大盘
抓得非常的精准的话
也欢迎加入
我会把订阅的连结放在留言的第一则
那就等您来啰